good morning John today I'm going to
dinner the Stuart my shirts inside out
tell you the story of my ridiculous dog
my dog is named lemon and she is bit of
how to put this delicately a dirt for
example if she were a Pulitzer
prize-winning novel she would be the
color dirt ball she were a sexually
transmitted disease she would be Herpa
derpa simplex if you were 19th century
law ma'am she'd be Wyatt dirt if she
were large species of sub-saharan
African mammal she would be a Herpa
derpa Potamus well it loves to get into
cars but hates to be inside of cars
she loves odd the little children's
section of the playground she hates dog
toys if she ever hears a toy squeak she
will never go within 5 feet of it ever
again crayons in general have oddly
shaped bodies which makes it hard for
them to sit down like normal dogs also
eye means it's hard it's not comfortable
to lay on their bellies so oftentimes
they lay on their backs we call this the
Rope she often sleeps with her eyes
partially open and twitches while she's
doing this which makes her look like a
freaky zombie dog the vocalizations of
the lemon are somewhat buried she does
bark but only very rarely she much
prefers to howl and their noises of
patheticness are so varied and nuanced
that she's earned the nickname lemonis
pathetic 'she is also afraid of the cat
lemons second favorite thing is to run
because it of course is what she was
bred to do though she's getting a little
older so she's not at her top speed
anymore on the track her top speed was
about 34 miles per hour point three
miles in less than 30 seconds in
addition to lemonis pathetic us we also
call her lemon chino limoncello lemon
pie liz LeMat is in fact the reason why
she is called lemon her Trek name was
Tina Fey interesting thing about
greyhounds unlike every other kind of
dog you can actually go onto a website
search for their name and find out
everything about what their litter mates
were named 39 generations of previous
sires and sisters and half-brothers and
half-sisters in every race they ever ran
in and how they did it also shows you
their ear tag numbers which is totally
strange till I see a number on a website
and also tattooed on the inside of your
dog's ear this one on this year actually
the five is the month she was born the
four is the year she was born so we know
that she was born in May 2004 this
website we learned all kinds of
fascinating things like that all of
lemons lid
was named after 2004 cast of Saturday at
land that Will Ferrell her brother was
the best racer of the litter winning 20
of his 63 rates and that lemons dad
Craig E Whistler sired over 5000 racing
dogs what's of course poor guy he wasn't
actually there for any of the conception
virgin births everyone a virgin birth
lemon is weary or even afraid of things
that she has an experience before and
when we first got her pretty much
everything was something that she hadn't
experienced before bicycles rivers
breeds of dog that weren't greyhounds
introduction of the green household was
a very confusing time for her but the
one thing that she took to immediately
was her third favorite thing after food
and running and that's cuddling and
she's just a cuddle bear and we love her
very much and if you are at all
interested in getting a dog you should
check your local area for greyhound
adoption agencies there lots that need
home my foots asleep
my foots asleep people who are asking
the project for awesome yes it's
happening December 17th and 18th we
should have the website up very soon but
before then you should be thinking
working on your videos for charitable
causes this was a good example of one
that might be a project for awesome
video but in fact isn't John I'll see
you on Friday